warst du beim tomatenpflanzen unbedingt
beachten solltest tomaten brauchen einen
geschützten standort ein gewächshaus ist
also perfekt aber du kannst die tomaten
zb auch auf die südseite einer mauer
pflanzen dann brauchen sie natürlich
noch eine stütze damit sie nicht
umkippen und dann haben wir ein loch das
breiter und tiefer ist als das töpfchen
deiner tomatenpflanze da kommt jetzt
noch ein langzeitdünger rein ich
verwende davon spiele nur gesteinsmehl
und bittersalz zu gleichen teilen jetzt
knipse ich von der tomatenpflanze die
alle untersten blätter ab und wenn die
wurzeln sich im topf so ein bisschen
kräuseln kannst du die lockern und dann
pflanzte die pflanze bis direkt unter
die untersten blätter ein und jetzt habe
ich noch einen trick für euch und zwar
mache ich immer so einen kleinen island
wie man hier sie zu einem kleinen weise
dass das wasser beim gießen auch dein
fließt wo es hin soll tomaten tipps auf
einem kanal